à washington que ce soit pour se rendre
au travail ou encore pour visiter la
capitale
les milliers de trottinettes électriques
permettent d'accélérer le rythme pour
soient résidents ou touristes
elle offre depuis près de deux ans des
déplacements rapides abordable et
divertissant je ne mentirai pas je
m'amuse comme un fou dit il
l'an dernier à doria doucette
attendaient avec impatience d'essayer ce
nouveau mode de transport
mais les choses ne se sont pas déroulées
comme prévu hélas couiza
elle raconte que ces frais ont fait
défaut et qu'elle est entrée en
collision avec un cycliste
résultat une jambe cassée mais le bilan
aurait pu être pire
comme beaucoup d'autres utilisateurs
adorent yade ou 7 ne portait pas de
casque à son hôpital du centre ville les
médecins qui est de gloss voit presque
quotidiennement des blessures liées au
trottinettes électriques notamment des
commotions cérébrales et des fractures
aux bras et aux jambes
et comme le phénomène est nouveau les
données sont rares à austin au texas
une étude récente a montré que près de
la moitié des patients admis à l'hôpital
s'était blessé à la tête
moins d'un pour cent d'entre eux portait
un casque qui est de glaces travaillent
maintenant à dresser le portrait dans sa
région
à washington la ville impose une vitesse
maximale de 16 kilomètres à l'heure et
détermine où il est possible de circuler
pour le reste elle demande aussi qu'on
panique elle a autorisé sur son
territoire de s'assurer de la sécurité
de leurs usagers
chaque mesure varie selon l'entreprise
spin par exemple assure examiner
régulièrement ses appareils en plus
d'imposer certaines conditions à ses
clients notamment être âgés de 18 ans ou
avoir un permis de conduire
je voudrais que vous devrez vous balader
avec un passager faut tout le temps être
être seul
le journaliste lautaro greenspan s'est
penché sur le phénomène la réaliser que
la sécurité repose beaucoup sur des
recommandations vous commencé à rouler
l'application store au téléphone musique
avoue te fais attention tu te prépares
tu es du casque mais c'est simplement
une
sur la suggestion pas une règle écrite à
noir sur blanc un coup d'oeil suffit
pour constater que les règlements ne
sont pas toujours connues ou respecter
les utilisateurs que nous avons
rencontrés ont toutefois affirmé se
sentir en sécurité
mais adrien doucet tu crois qu'il faut
développer une réglementation plus clair
et mieux éduquer la population depuis
son accident un an s'est écoulé et elles
peinent encore à marcher
celle qui a appris à la dure qu'il n'y a
pas que du bon avec cette invention
espère que son témoignage servira de
leçon ici rappelle bouvy auclair
radio-canada washington